we have a Richard Schiff from the good
doctor coming up an hour number three
but now returning to the Rich Eisen show
one of our favorite guests last time we
spoke to to this man we were in
Pittsburgh PA for Thursday Night
Football prior to the ultimate
destruction of Marcus Mariota and the
Titans that night he's in rampage in
theaters near you right now has been
there since last Friday starring along
with the rock and Jeffrey Dean Morgan
Joe Manganiello good to see you again
senior ish I I don't know how to
introduce you maybe I could introduce
you as well as the man who shares the
same nutritionist as Antonio Brown yeah
yeah it's not the fact is that that's
how I got ahold of him yeah there was
Steelers ownership put me in touch with
this guy who was working with a bee who
had previously I guess Pete Carroll
brought him to to diagnose and the
entire Seattle Seahawks team and then
they won that year and then the
following year the Patriots brought him
in to work with the Patriots and then
they won that year and then the
following year Carolina heard about it
and they wound up going to the Super
Bowl but not win so basically anything
anybody this guy touches has a breakout
year the secret sauce and the NFL has
been a nutritionist all these past few
years the other saying yeah I mean if
you're looking for advantage for example
you know players get in trouble for
injecting performance-enhancing drug
I've heard of that story yes so but
here's the thing when you eat you're
guessing what you should be eating this
guy goes in takes ten vials of your
blood about two weeks later it comes
back and gives you 26 pages worth of
results and tells you exactly what you
should be eating what you're deficient
in some some Co Q 10 supplement that you
buy at Whole Foods could completely
unblock your testosterone and then so
business booms in particular of one wide
receiver
yeah and that regard for us yeah and
Ryan shazier was was working with him as
well and you know he he went to the Pro
Bowl so pretty much any anybody this guy
talks to it's the idea is that he can
create the same effect inside internally
that that players go players have been
gotten in trouble for trying to do
externally unbelievable yeah and now I
give them to you
- is gonna be exponentially faster next
year
I am biohacking your 40 times okay
is that is that legal but was this legal
is on the up it's like eat this versus
this and take a bite take this vitamin
which will help you out and your body is
designed to eat red meat versus fish not
how do I not do this right well this
goes back to what we talked about every
single year rich are you gonna take this
seriously and train and get your body
and mind ready to really run a fantastic
40 I'll give you another example yes Joe
Manganiello I gave this guy for for
Christmas I got this diagnosis of this
trainer for my trainer Ron you've met
hmm and he went on to win the CrossFit
masters that year do you get a green
jacket for that when you win the
CrossFit Massacre dragon tank top you
wear that three straight weeks you get
green olie shoes is what you get oh my
gosh now I know you were working out
with a mountain right from Game of
Thrones yeah I went to Iceland and I
went to Thor's power gym and I worked
out with with Thor Thor's power gym by
the way that's another great fantasy
team writing Thor's power gym be great
team name fantasy team name yeah
so I went it was a heat when we got
there he said okay what do you guys want
to live today and I said why don't we do
legs anyone because he had just squatted
927 the day before that was my that was
my version of a joke let's do legs
by the way 927 according to Mike Bell -
food would be 9 plates of 27 right yeah
if they had a 27 pounds so so Joe can
he's been working out our audio
executive okay and he says he could he
could he said he could plank 125 well
what is it 145 145 he says he could
plank 145 what does that mean to you
when you hear plank 145 Bank 145 yes
what is it is it like when they bring
out the alive sushi table when they lay
the sushi table there and they put the
sushi on top and you all eat off to some
naked person no when he's like I'm these
planking with a 45-pound plate
no no late that he would get into a
plank position yes and plank 1:45 what
does that mean what do you think when
you hear that that means what in a plank
145 no B I said plank 145 is this like
an is this had something to do with
nautical term no he's he says it that he
would plate one one plate of 45 pounds
one plate because we're like you cannot
plank 145 pounds and there he is on
screen with Michael Irvin barking out
instructions to him right here so this
is what I thought actually that's 90
pounds on his back right there this is
great how long did you go a minute
a solid minute all right yeah down he
was bark item and everything I played
flag football with Michael Irvin one
year for Madden okay and it was Michael
Irvin was on the other team Kurt Warner
it's how I met Kurt Kurt was
quarterbacking with Michael Irvin Rod
Woodson and Shannon Sharpe and Michael
Irvin popped his Achilles in like the
first quarter that was here in Southern
California right I was there too you
were in the action with Marshall
Marshall yeah I caught a touchdown for
Jill Montana that game I mean do you
imagine like seriously I mean I go into
the huddle of this flag football game
and we're in the huddle and Joe Montana
looks at me and goes it's coming to you
like pinch me right yes my last football
game in high school was against Joe's
high school Ringel lose like it's coming
to you so I come out of he always run a
post pattern I'm gonna hit you back
corner in the ends how nervous were you
break well we come out Deon comes up to
me back he goes hey he goes break he
goes break for your post at the 5-yard
line
I'm gonna take your guy out like
dealin's that competitor so he was
running then he was running the route
with you so I hit the five-yard line
broke into my post pattern and just
jacked whoever was guarding me and Joe
put her right there for a session that's
it amazing where does that compare to
doing what you do professionally what
you have done professionally oh where
does that compare well I mean you know
there are comparisons I mean like doing
a movie with honors Schwarzenegger
that was another one you know being in
like hair and makeup in the morning and
talking to Arnold and realizing we're
gonna go shoot a movie together there's
peers you know that was a big deal you
know getting a call from Paul Reubens
saying do you want to play pee-wee
Herman's best friend a movie Paul
Reubens and Joe Montana are on the are
in a similar level you look at it that
way it's like you mean you know cuz then
you get the set and he's in his
pee-wee's suit and you're there and you
really you have to you have to play the
scene and you're this I can't believe
I'm talking to be what pee-wee is
talking to me like peewee yeah yeah it's
in a bizarre bizarro universe I think
they're two 60-second break come back I
want to hit you up on what it's like to
be with the rock right now and you want
to talk about crazy crazy crazy huge
success going on right now and long with
your success with some of these great
movies that you've been in lately I want
to hit up what what is did you do any
workouts with the rock come on you know
I'm gonna tell you something I mean this
is giving away part of the movie well
then hold on it don't give that away
let's do that in 60 seconds when we come
back that's we do that and I do want to
I want to hit you up on because Billy
Gardell was here a couple weeks ago and
he had quite a lot to say about levy on
bail I want your two cents what do you
think your stealers should do with levy
on bail in this Sidney Crosby for the
good stuff that's coming up next year
with Joe Manganiello in 60 seconds
[Music]
alright Joe Manganiello here another
segment at Joe Manganiello on Twitter
and on Instagram as well follow this man
rampage in theaters near you right now
what was this like being on the set with
the rock for a huge budget monster
picture well so I don't want to give too
much away but the rock was off with the
gorilla while I was off with the wolf
okay
so there wasn't much only give too much
away okay you know whether or not we our
paths cross you have to go see the room
what about in the gym in the gym no I I
had my squatted eyes in the film and I
worked out with them we never never got
to work out okay so any sort of answer
would be a spoiler alert is what you're
saying correct yeah I don't want to
spoil anything all right so you're
Steelers down hmm what do you think they
should do with loving on Bill Pam look I
mean there's market value and I mean
he's a running back so what are you
gonna do you wanted he's why but I mean
you take a look at his numbers compared
to Sammy Watkins for instance and then
out they're not all 2 & 3 yard dump
passes either it's not just him in the
flat going two steps out and we see he's
wide he's wide creating matchup
nightmare certainly when there's Antonio
Brown and juju Smith Schuster to deal
with here so ok well this is the Jay
this is the Jimmy Graham argument well
it is the Jimmy Graham argument are you
[ __ ] but everyone knows that he's a
wide receiver not really a tight end -
okay he might wind up but as a Titan
he's not blocking anybody that was the
problem in Seattle nobody ever thought
okay they're gonna run the football here
cuz Jimmy Graham's on the field and they
didn't run it all refresh my memory what
was the resolution on the Jimmy Graham
said they made of a tighter right but
look there has to be some sort of middle
ground cuz this guy 5500 catches more
than Sammy Watkins last year
okay well then he and he had and you
look what Sammy Watkins did in free
agency well Sammy should complain to his
quarterback his coach I don't know what
to say you know I mean Marshall Faulk
Thurman Thomas these are great receiving
that correct where they paid his
receivers or where they paid his running
back I mean it was a different market
then and I think that's really the
argument that's happening hmm but is
that is that the Steelers job to then
break the market or change the market as
he as he put it you know I mean is is
that our issue or is that just the fact
that the running back position has been
devalued so you have a guy asking for
money but we're making in the highest
paid running back in the league at some
point it's you have to abandon this idea
that you're going to reset the market
for running backs in today's world
because that's that's not the case he's
a very unique player don't get me wrong
but he's not a Antonio Brown he's not a
wide receiver he does play running back
unless he does finally keep getting
franchise tag to the point where he it
can't happen anymore and then he does
test the open market well and that's
where that's what we're headed to so you
know but I mean the the and I understand
that the guy has grievances in terms of
contract but there's some off-the-field
stuff too that hopefully you know stops
being such a distraction because there's
also a part of that as well do you think
this dealer should take a quarterback in
the draft I mean it depends on who we
can get you know third fourth round
because that would be it would be
picking a guy in the same position that
we picked Josh Dobbs last year I mean we
have needs other than that that I think
the best player at inside linebacker the
best player at outside linebacker the
best defensive back those guys need to
come off the board and need to be
drafted in those first few rounds I
think right now mm-hmm that's that's my
yeah cuz Big Ben is kind of on that
year-to-year thing right now it looks
like the Favre I don't know if I'm gonna
oh yeah I'll do it well he was last year
but I think personally the wavering last
year was a message being sent to certain
people that changes needed to be made to
get rid of Todd Haley III mean I threw
your words I know but I think that that
was a shot across the bow that was a
message and I think the message was
received I think that Ben is excited I
mean it sounds like Ben's excited to
play this year there were some changes
that way that's not we have not heard
him say you know I'm thinking of my
football mentality I don't know how many
years I have left we have not heard
thought this year and he's not getting
mauled the way that he used to I mean
the first those two Super Bowls that we
won and then the one that that we lost
and with Ben
we had a real patchwork offensive line
during that time the offensive line was
really I think one of the weaknesses on
our squad and we still managed to win
the Super Bowls now it's the strength so
Ben's not taking the pounding that he
that he's taking and I think you know
he's got a offensive coordinator that
he's approves of he's got a great
offense around him I mean why wouldn't
you stick around and see what could
happen couple more minutes left with Joe
Manganiello here you what did you
voiceover for the Penguins what did you
do what was I did the the 50-year
comprehensive Penguins documentary
Pittsburgh is home it's uh the 50-year
history of the Penguins so where where
do you think Sidney Crosby sits in the
pantheon of Pittsburgh sports already
right now where do you think he sits
well you know we had this conversation
before about about Lemieux and I think
that Lemieux is is the number one
Pittsburgh sports legend or icon if you
will any of the the major teams yes okay
because when when do you ever have an
another player who went through what he
went through battle cancer battled the
back surgery and then came back
continued to play and then Oh liquidated
his assets bought the team and kept them
from leaving the city that's he's a
savior so but I think as far as Crosby
goes I mean Crosby is one of the
all-time NHL greats period and I know
people are gonna come after me cuz
whatever but I don't I don't care that
guy is unbelievable you watch the
playoffs that he's having right now and
you look at his resume he's incredible
he's absolutely unbelievable he's one of
the all-time Pittsburgh yeah I mean him
there he's gay years to play he does
have years to play it's unbelievable so
what what's next on tap for you anything
you want to promote that's going on
right now other than rampage what's next
for me just go see rampage go see the
number one movie in the world there you
go see the number one movie in the world
and you're gonna give me your your your
Rainmaker who will make me faster that's
it yeah I'm telling you alright we're
gonna we're in a biohacking rich so by
is that's a good thing right
being bio hacked very good nam us
good to see you Joe Manganiello thanks
for coming on the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience